it is eight o'clock this is scania's
breakfast and these are our top stories
cut off russia is to stop sending
electricity supplies to finland as
tensions grow over helsinki's desire to
join nato
the worst is over ukraine's spy chief
tells sky news there are moves for a
coup against president putin and the one
with russia could be over by the end of
the year
a royal visit prince william goes in
person to the home of deborah james to
give her her demon
the government delays its plans to ban
buy one get one free deals on unhealthy
foods all part of a response to the cost
of living crisis
the link between the high cost of living
and the strain on mental health we visit
burnley where one in eight people are on
universal credit
people feeling that their backs up
against the wall
that there's nowhere to go
which then affect their mental health
and becoming more despondent
for he's a jolly wood fellow the first
beaver born and exhibit in 400 years
celebrates his first birthday
as a quarter too we'll take a final run
through the papers with badesha and
matthew stadlin
and it is a big day in the football
calendar we'll be looking ahead to the
fa cup final where liverpool play
chelsea at wembley stadium
[Music]
morning all russia is cutting off
electricity supplies to finland from
today the move seen by many as
retaliation for finland's desire to join
nato has been blamed by the russian
supply company on finland not paying its
bills the news comes as ukraine's
military spy chief has told sky news
there are moves for a coup to topple
president putin and that the war with
russia will be over by the end of the
year
the russian supply company has said it
will suspend electricity supplies to
finland today amidst rising tensions
over helsinki's bid to join nato
meanwhile ukraine's prosecutor general
has said her office is preparing 41 war
crimes cases against russian soldiers
and ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski has said talks with russia to
evacuate wounded soldiers from the azov
style plant in mariupol are underway in
his nightly address to his country
president zielinski also said russian
forces were taking heavy losses
today we can report the 200th downed
russian military airplane
russia hasn't lost so much aviation in
any of its wars in decades
russia has also lost 27 000 soldiers
many of whom were young conscripts
russia has lost more than 3 000 tanks
armored vehicles drones and all of its
perspectives as a state
well as mentioned ukraine's military spy
chief has told sky news a coup is
brewing against vladimir putin and that
the war with russia will be over by the
end of the year speaking after a series
of military successes by ukrainian
forces against russian maneuvers
major general carrillo badanov claims
that ukraine knows everything about
russia's plans quotes almost as they are
being made well after failing to take
the capital russia is now focusing its
efforts on the donbass region
there's intense fighting in the cities
of israel crimina sever donetsk and
mario paul with the intention it's
understood to encircle specialist
ukrainian troops in the east
ukraine has been pushing back though
notably around kharkiv in the north and
make alive in the south
and the spy chief told our international
affairs editor dominic wakon that is a
sign of things to come
he forecast russia's invasion of ukraine
where most didn't think it would happen
and now ukraine's top military spy has
another prediction for how the war it
started will end
major carrillo budanov has watched
ukraine's enemies up close and
scrutinized their moves and goes further
russia's defeat he says will be
disastrous for both its leader and his
country
that does mean a politician
rumors about putin's ill health he says
are confirmed by ukrainian intelligence
russia is suffering huge losses the
general says an entire battalion wiped
out trying to cross this river in
dinettes
and in the area around hakeev its forces
push back almost to the russian border
russia's much vaunted modernized
military has proved itself a myth in
ukraine he says whatever image it likes
to project
[Music]
we are in an information war propaganda
spewed by both sides but this is the
first time a senior official here has
said when the war will end
a sign of growing confidence their enemy
will be beaten what are your feelings
now my feelings now yeah
optimistic
dominic waghorn sky news cleave
and we can speak to our international
affairs editor dominic wagon good to see
you dom um
let's pick up on the last point in your
report in fact like a man who is a
military spy chief knows a thing or two
about disinformation so so should we
take everything he says with a seller of
salt
i think to a certain extent i mean we
are in an information wall there's a lot
of propaganda being thrown around by
both sides his office was fascinating it
was stuff full of the paraphernalia of
war a lamp stand was it was a rifle uh
there were machine guns piled up behind
his desk he had a machine gun a magazine
that was used as a paperweight and he
had this chess set on the table and how
much of that was for show how much it
was generally because he is a spy chief
gathering intelligence in the heart of
war it's unclear but i think what we
have to say about him is is that even
though we are hearing about a lot of
propaganda he is someone whose
predictions have been proven correct in
the past when most of the world
including a lot of the members of his
government last year and in the run-up
to the invasion were pretty skeptical
about the chances of russia invading
ukraine didn't think it would happen he
stuck his neck out and said yes it would
happen and he said when he said the end
of january the beginning of february so
a little bit early but otherwise he was
spot on and he seemed very assured very
confident and certain in his conclusions
and i said how can he be sure and he
said i'm not predicting it i know it i
see the intelligence i see the evidence
what's frustrating is he wouldn't say
what will happen in august to create
that turning point that would then shift
the war decisively in ukraine's favor
and then the war would end by the end of
the year but he said it would be a
combination of political and military uh
factors so some speculation as a team we
had as we left was it could be to do
with putin's health did he know
something about putin's health that is
going to lead to him deteriorating and
possibly dying by august because uh
buddha has also said in the past the war
will end with putin's death he's pretty
certain that putin is very ill he's got
cancer and a number of other illnesses
and he says his defeat russia's defeat
in this war will not just be bad news
for the russian leader but will lead to
russia falling apart into four different
regions so take that as you as you will
but do bear in mind here somebody has
made predictions in the past and they've
been correct
dominic many thanks
prince william has visited the cancer
awareness champion deborah james at her
home to give her her dame hood it comes
as the total raised for cancer research
by the campaigner and podcast host has
surpassed 5 million pounds the 40 year
old who was diagnosed with cancer in
2016 shared a little earlier in the week
that she had begun end of life care as
her body simply wasn't playing ball
sally lockwood reports on a campaigner
sure to leave a remarkable legacy
deborah james has danced her way to a
dang hood since her cancer diagnosis
she's not wasted a moment
even after breaking the news she was
beginning end-of-life care the royal
marsden hospital is one of the chosen
beneficiaries of her fundraising
it's been an emotional week for her
consultant who's treated deborah for
more than five years
you know i learned a lot from deborah
about about the human endeavor
about the challenges that cancer
patients face and also she came up with
a few good research ideas that we
discussed i can't go out
i'm sick
[Music]
deborah james used her social media
platform bowel babe to break the taboos
of cancer
her podcast you me in the big c
propelled the deputy head teacher to
fame
her final episode was recorded after
she'd begun end of life care
i hope that anyone who's listened to the
pod he has
read one of my columns read my book or
looks on my instagram and stuff will
i suppose
if they can afford to buy me a
gin and tonic to send me on my way and
by doing so hopefully we can raise some
money for these charities
deborah was speaking to her podcast
producer this week after she'd announced
she'd ended active care
when i look down i see it's deborah i'll
think wow what's this going to be next
you know what's gonna what's the next
idea devs
and uh
i'll miss her
that's what i miss
deborah james often dressed up to spread
the word for people to get checked
tributes so often come too late after
someone is no longer with us
for deborah james the nation has been
able to show their love and appreciation
with one of the country's highest honors
i suppose
that's it from me i can't believe it
that that is it for me
enjoy life because it is so precious
it's
all i want right now is more time and
more life
um
and
i would also check your p
sally lockwood sky news
and let's take a quick look at the total
amount raised by deborah well as you can
see over five and a half million pounds
in fact that's up 60 000 pounds in just
the last hour yeah that's gonna hit six
million before too long
now the high court has ruled that a 12
year old boy who suffered catastrophic
brain damage should undergo a test so
that doctors can try to establish
whether his brain is still alive it's
still active i should say
archie battersby who's from south end
hasn't regained consciousness after
suffering brain damage in an incident
more than a month ago
the judge concluded that a brain stem
test would be an archie's best interests
his mother however
is urging the court to give her son some
more time
he's just a beautiful beautiful innocent
child
he's brought every single day since that
baby was born
he just put a smile on my face he's made
me laugh he's just a beautiful little
boy
he's happy he's active he's got
beautiful personality he's kind he loves
he loves animals he's sensitive
the queen has made her first public
appearance since she missed the state
opening of parliament on tuesday she
attended the royal windsor horse show
watching her animals take to the parade
ring and was delighted to be there she
was last seen in public at prince
philip's memorial service in
march
big screens will be set up in britain's
capital cities so that people can watch
the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations
screens broadcasting the events will be
placed in palmer at prince's street
gardens in edinburgh and in butte park
in cardiff across the bank holiday
weekend
now foreign ministers of the g7 will
conclude talks today which have been
taking place in germany ukraine was top
of the agenda with diplomats pledging to
provide more military aid in what they
called a powerful sign of unity uh the
co-founder of the council on geo
strategy james rogers joins us now james
very good morning to you um
i wonder what you may have made and of
the
what seems like pending move uh by both
sweden and finland
to get into nato what what is your
assessment of how much that shakes the
kaleidoscope so to speak
yeah good morning to be with you um
this is quite a significant move because
of course finland and sweden remained
primarily neutral during the cold war
and although they moved closer towards
nato and of course with their membership
of the european union the western
position
during the aftermath of the cold war
they're now seeking direct
nato membership the
president and prime minister of finland
issued a statement two days ago and then
sweden uh issued a report yesterday
which confirmed that they see the
deterioration of the european strategic
situation they believe that russia is an
increasingly unpredictable state even
more unpredictable than the soviet union
was and that this requires them both to
move towards membership of nato and of
course a couple of days before that uh
boris johnson visited both capitals to
issue security assurances to both um
both uh countries
so what then do we make of a potential
um uh opposition coming from from turkey
i mean do they have do they have the
casting votes in all of this how much
sway does everyone really have in in
capitals like washington london soar
well it requires unanimity for a new
member to join the alliance so
turkey could cause um problems however
some analysts believe that it's more a
case that turkey might be seeking some
kind of concessions rather than seeking
to block them uh outright and of course
countries like the us and the uk which
provide the mainstay of the resources
and strategic wherewithal of the
alliance had some
say over
the ultimate direction shall we say but
it could cause some diplomatic uh
wrangling in order to uh uh placate the
turks and allow both sweden and finland
uh in
we had an interview we've been carrying
on the channel an interview with our
interface between our international
affairs editor and uh the head of
defense intelligence for ukraine a
couple of uh eye-raising kind of lines
coming out of that first of course that
there could be an end in sight to the
war the second that there is potentially
a coup building in moscow i mean how
much validity should we give to those in
the absence of any further evidence
i think that's difficult to say i mean i
think the russian objective has changed
of course initially it was to seize kiev
in a sort of lightning strike that
failed and then the russians tried to
use heavy armor to surround and circle
and then uh seize the city that also
failed so now they are moving
increasingly to operations uh in the
east of ukraine where they already have
um a degree of of influence now the
russians have always uh sought i think
over the last let's say eight years
since they invaded ukraine back in 2014
uh to engage in what's called non-linear
warfare that is to say to uh actually
provoke and promote conflict in the
country in order to to drag it down uh
and to prevent it from moving towards uh
both nato and the european union which
of course is what ukraine has been
seeking uh to do so there might be an
objective here within russia to actually
just prolong the conflict without end in
order to to prevent ukraine from
consolidating and joining uh joining the
west now on the terms of uh a coup in in
in moscow uh that is a possibility but
at this stage i think it is very
unlikely uh the uh putin regime has some
degree of control over the country uh
and has built that up over the last uh
20 odd years
but nonetheless it is true that the the
regime's war in ukraine has failed
miserably so far and that's becoming
increasingly apparent to the russian
people it is no longer a special
military operation as the kremlin calls
it but it has become increasingly an
outright war and a war as we've seen
with some pretty horrendous uh
consequences
and actions undertaken by the russians
and i think this despite the regime's
control over the media space has become
increasingly apparent to the russian
people
as well as of course the russian
political and economic elites and in
that context uh you know a coup in the
long run or regime change within the
country cannot be entirely i think ruled
out
how then is this information getting to
to the russian public given the strangle
that they have on the media given that
the controls that they place uh on the
internet and and also i mean this week
of course it was victory victory day
parade and lots of russian eyes will
have been on that but it was a it was a
drastically reduced victory day parade
by my reckoning
yeah i i think it primarily through word
of mouth and information that's seeping
through from uh
the soldiers that have been uh sent to
ukraine to fight getting back to their
families uh and other forms of of
information exchange like that uh of
course as you'll rightly point out that
the the regime does continue to have a
strong hold over the information that
the russian people uh are able to access
great to have you in the program this
morning thanks very much for joining us
thank you
now the government is to delay a ban on
buy one get one free deals for unhealthy
food products because of what it says is
the unprecedented squeeze on living
standards
joins us once again in the studio i mean
we have when we've been chatting this
morning been focusing on the bog off
aspect of what the government's
announced they've also announced though
that that ban on advertising junk food
to children before the watershed
that's not coming in
what's that about because it can't be to
do with the cost of living crisis that's
right that ban is pushed back until
january 2024 at the earliest and
according to newspaper reports it sounds
like ministers have told the prime
minister that this would have an
economic impact on the food and drink
industry therefore he shouldn't go
forward with those changes we also know
that those food and drink companies
spend millions on advertising with big
broadcasters critics will say that that
is putting the economy and politics
before the health of our nation's
children and it's interesting how
political this issue has now become they
are saying that the government had its
own targets his own benchmark which is
2030 being the uh the target of uh
cutting childhood obesity
that is not going to be met they say if
they put the
economics first uh it's it's an
interesting one i think the government
will have a lot to to have to justify
not just on the bog off deals but also
like you say on this advertising as well
yeah i have to wait for the politicians
to get back to work on monday for the
program to start but it will come after
nationally thank you
is spreading through the secret and of
course unvaccinated state of north korea
the country's leader kim jong-un has
said his country is facing a great
disaster
after 21 deaths were reported from
people who had apparently suffered a
fever the state news agency didn't
mention covert 19 but said around 280
000 people were being treated and 27 had
lost their lives since late april
at least 27 people have been killed
after a fire broke out in a four-story
building on the outskirts of india's
capital delhi
firefighters battled to extinguish the
flames for almost five hours and have
begun a search operation to look for
anyone trapped in the rubble
the office of new zealand's prime
minister jacinda ardern has said she's
tested positive for coronavirus and is
suffering from moderate symptoms it
comes just days after the government
announced the relaxation of the
country's tight border controls which
have been enforced since the start of
the pandemic
let's see how the weekend's weather is
looking
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a quiet start to the weekend high
pressure drifting by which will help to
keep the conditions settled but the
weather will become more changeable from
sunday onwards although it will stay
rather warm this morning any early mist
should clear to sunshine cloud will
drift on and off western coasts but it
should be dry for most with some good
sunny spells the sun will be strong
lifting temperatures to a high of 23 or
even 24 degrees celsius uv levels will
be high along with the pollen count the
fine conditions will last into the
evening away from the southwest where
shower outbreaks will spread in
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
welcome back quick reminder as to our
top stories and the russian supply
company raun nordic has said it will
suspend electricity to finland today
amidst rising tensions over helsinki's
bid to join nato
the cancer campaigner and podcast host
deborah james has been given a demon by
prince william at her home
and the government is to delay a ban on
buying one get one free deals for
unhealthy food products
now as mental health services report
increased demands due to the strain of
rising costs sky news has spoken to
families relying on a church in burnley
for financial and mental health support
almost a third of people in the town
live in fuel poverty and one in every
eight claim universal credit skies
fraser mod reports
for mother of nine lindsay life has
never been easy yeah it's always been a
struggle trying to consistently make
sure that they have the right
necessities that they need
now the cost of living crisis is adding
to her anxiety and damaging her already
fragile mental health
i'm on a lot of high medication i have
been my whole life basically
and
if it wasn't for the medication i'd take
i don't think i'd be able to sleep at
night i don't think i'd be able to think
properly i'd be constantly worried and
depressed and
just fear for my kids basically that i'm
not doing right by them
lindsay gets help and support here the
church on the street run by the man
known as pastor mick it's a non-funded
center providing financial spiritual and
mental health advice for those most in
need and the cost of living crisis is
adding to the problem i think slowly but
surely numbers are growing slowly but
surely you're going bigger and bigger
and i find that people feeling that
their back's up against the wall
that they've nowhere to go
which then affects their mental health
and becoming more despondent and and
more depression settled in in a town
where the number of people claiming
universal credit has gone up by over 50
percent in the last two years the need
for pasta mix help is greater than ever
is there a direct relationship between
the cost of living crisis and people's
mental health yeah so where there's
poverty there's anxiety
there's not knowing where you're going
to get your next meal from there isn't
knowing uh kind of whether you can put
gas and electric cars there's the how am
i going to pay the top up for my housing
how am i going to get through that that
causes stress anxiety physical and of
course mental health problems
the new partnership between the church
and the nhs allows health professionals
to provide a gateway to more traditional
services
i really believe by doing this more
outreach work as we would call it is
definitely benefiting people and
bridging you know and bridging the gap
and helping those people you know who
have perhaps been disadvantaged the
charity mental health uk says the number
of people contacting them for mental
health and financial advice has gone up
by over 96 in the past 12 months
and with inflation still on the up it
seems theirs and pastor mix fears of a
mental health pandemic may sadly be all
too prophetic
fraser moored sky news burnley
just a reminder that next week kate will
be taking her show on the road for a
special series of programs she'll be
going back to our roots and finding out
how the people of wigan feel about the
cost of living crisis all that at the
usual time from monday
elon musk has said his 36 billion pound
takeover of twitter is temporarily on
hold so will it happen some have accused
him of not being entirely serious about
the bid from the start i will let's get
the latest from social media expert matt
navarro matt great to see you this
morning um well let's let's start with
the practicalities of it what exactly is
it that elon musk is complaining about
at the moment as regards bot accounts on
twitter why is this a sticking point
well this is all the craziness of this
deal he's come out now this late hour
and suggested that twitter he's got
concerns that there's more than five
percent which is the amount of spam and
uh bot accounts that twitter has
disclosed and it's disclosed for some
time he feels like it could be more now
and because he thinks there could be
more he wants to check that because he's
a bit concerned about whether he wants
to continue with the deal but this is
something that twitter has disclosed
many times and it's the number that's uh
it's been in their documents and he had
the opportunity as part of the deal to
do an advanced kind of due diligence
exercise before kind of signing the
contract and he chose not to do it so
it's rather surprising at this late
stage that he's throwing this curved
ball in
rather surprising i'm wondering if
euphemistically you are perhaps
suggesting that he might not have been
entirely serious about this from the
get-go certainly there are a lot of
people who are coming to that conclusion
yeah there's lots of competing theories
as to why he's saying this now one of
them is that he you know the tech stocks
have taken a huge hammering on the
markets recently and the value of
twitter has dropped significantly and
also the value of his own tesla stocks
which he's using to fund the deal has
gone down making the deal even more
expensive so it could be that this is a
angling for a way to back out of the
deal it could be he's angry to get a
discount on on the price of twitter but
also he's very unpredictable and kind of
likes to be the center of attention with
this sort of stuff and it could just be
it was friday the 13th and elon musk
wanted to have some fun
yeah yeah there is that of course uh you
know elon musk has been talking an awful
lot about donald trump recently donald
trump has been talking about elon musk
he makes the point and you've got to say
donald trump does know a thing or two
about large sums of money he makes the
point that from his perspective twitter
was overpriced i mean is there perhaps
some truth in that
possibly and you know twitter has got
lots of issues not not only the fact
that this deal is such a mess but you
know it could be fair to say that that
it has been overpriced and that there is
some
possibility that uh a discount could be
uh could be reasonable but at this stage
in the proceedings and given all the
things that go on so far it's just yet
another kind of nightmare problem for
twitter which whatever happens with this
deal twitter is the one that's going to
be the loser in all of this and of
course the staff that work for the
company and the users that love the
product it really is a complete and not
a mess yeah just just on that point then
is it perhaps is perhaps the reason this
deal has stalted something rather more
present rather more straightforward in
fact actually you know for all his hopes
of turning it into some kind of free
speech utopia the practicalities
surrounding doing that would almost make
it impossible
i think he's slowly coming to the
realization potentially that that this
is not going to be as straightforward as
maybe he first thought you know some of
his languages used in interviews
recently about content moderation and
the fact that he met the even one of the
eu leaders to do with the regulation
that the eu's bringing in and the fact
that he will you know align twitter to
that follow some of those rules so shows
a little bit of nuance in the fact that
he's going to have to sort of bend to
what is going to be needed for for
managing such a complex
content platform like twitter so i do
think that he may have bitten off more
they can chew and it could be one step
that he's taking now to kind of step
away from from this nightmare situation
matt nevada good to talk to you this
morning have a lovely weekend thank you
now the eurovision song contest reaches
its grand final this evening in turin
with ukraine italy and believe it or not
the united kingdom among the favorites
to win
[Music]
[Music]
after two consecutive last place
finishes and more than a decade in fact
since the uk made the top ten at this
man sam ryder a construction worker
turned tick-tock star his second
favorite to win with his entry space man
[Music]
but if he is to win he'll have to beat
odds-on favorites ukraine's rap folk
crossover band i didn't even know that
was a thing at callish orchestra the
group were hotly tipped to take the
grand prize even before russia's
invasion
uh joining us now journalist and of
course eurovision expert caroline
westbrook caroline lovely to see you
this morning
let's get let's get the british entry
out of the way shall we look so long so
often have i heard that you know what
this is going to be our year we're going
to do well and then finally all i have
ringing in my ears are the words no
point that i'm going to say i'm a bit
skeptical about this are you are you
convinced that we're going to have a
good showing tonight okay
it's understandable that you know to be
skeptical you've you've heard there's so
many times that we're going to do well
and and it doesn't happen
um i am here to tell you that you can
throw that skepticism out of the window
because i think we really do have a
chance of doing well this year
um you know it's it's as far aside for
the fact it is a very good song um
samurai is a fantastic performer he's
got an amazing voice i've seen the
the footage of you know the rehearsals
he's done in chewing which has been up
on youtube it yeah it's it's absolutely
amazing it's it's in you know it's a
different league from some of the stuff
we've sent in recent years
um i mean obviously there's a sense of
dissent and disbelief in the uk that we
could we could genuinely do well at this
but you know i've been saying for years
that
you know if you do get the right song
the right singer and the and the whole
package it's not just about having a
song that you can remember you've got to
actually be able to perform it well and
stage it well and we've kind of ticked
all those boxes this year
um so you know you anyone can genuinely
do well at this if you if you look at
the card i know there's this whole thing
about you know neighbourly voting and
this that and the other but you know if
you look at the countries that have
won in recent years this there's a huge
kind of diversity of countries that
don't necessarily benefit from the the
so-called neighborly voting blocks that
have won because they've said really
really good songs and you know they
perform them really really well and then
on the night you know that's been what
the voters have gone for let's let's
then let's let's because we're pushed
for time let's then talk about the
the favorites the ukrainian entry which
apparently i'm told as a folk rap
crossover that's a venn diagram that
i've never encountered before and just
tell us a little bit about them because
apparently you know they're quite good
and even before the invasion you know
we're being tipped for for from top
place i i personally this i personally
would have thought this song even you
know even before everything has happened
would uh
would be a contender for the top five
this kind of thing always does very very
well at eurovision and ukraine always
put up like a very very good showing um
obviously the song's taken on a lot of
extra meaning a lot of extra resonance
in the wake of the conflict and
i i think it'll be a very very worthy
winner um obviously a lot's gonna depend
on how the voting goes on the night
because fifty percent of the votes are
given by
juries that come across europe music
experts so
it's obviously gonna get a huge televote
we're just going to have to wait and see
how it does with jurors as well
just just very quickly if we can because
jackie belter our sports presenter and
of course eurovision aficionado
alerted me to it norway two men in masks
singing a song about giving a banana to
a wolf what yeah it's it's it's the
accommodation i've been wanting at
eurovision for ages it's
the most eurovision meets the master
singer what can i say um
yeah it's it's um give that wolf a
banana by the mysterious duo subwoofer
um two guys in yellow masks um yeah this
has everything this has a dance routine
this has a catchy chorus uh you're gonna
be up on your feet you're gonna be
wanting to practice the moves uh nobody
knows who they are it doesn't matter
because it's
brilliant caroline pleasure to talk to
you i will be looking forward to seeing
them talking about giving that willfully
banana at later on this series
thanks from
your time thank you
oh
from one story to another oh yes new
footage released released of the first
beaver born in eczema for 400 years at
well it's also market's first birthday
uh the young beaver named rashford has
been regularly spotted with its parents
on the national trust hollencott estate
in somerset since it was born last year
to mark the occasion the conservation
charity has released new footage of the
nice beaver on a static camera at
rashford was hard at work damn building
and moving mud with his dad yogi
almost 8 47 after the break we have
round three of the papers in the company
of the journalist padisha and the writer
matthew
[Music]
welcome back time for a final run
through the papers uh with the
broadcaster and journalist padisha and
the writer matthew stadlin and of course
we are pushed for time guys so let's go
straight on into it matt your first
story page four of the express the
european union attempting to punish the
united kingdom after brexit i mean who'd
have thought it
who'd have thought i could be really
quick in this one because i desperate to
get the dog who went to the pub story in
later meals don't worry we will get it
on i promise don't you worry
this is about jacob rees-mogg he's the
the secretary of state for brexit
opportunities if there are such things
and you guess what i voted for and and
also for government efficiency and he's
basically saying that the eu is trying
to punish britain for brexiting for
leaving the eu this is a story that has
been rumbling on and is now reaching
fever pitch it's about the sort of de
facto border down the irish sea the
checks on goods between britain and
northern ireland the dup desperately
against the northern ireland protocol
because it aligns northern ireland with
the rest of ireland
and this is a huge story because of
course it was boris johnson's government
who negotiated the brexit deal and
they're now considering whether it's
bluff or not ripping up a significant
part of it so you might blame boris
johnson's government you might blame the
eu but the consequences of what happens
if they do rip this up and possibly
extreme because there could be a trade
war we've already got massive inflation
as we're talking about earlier in this
country and within the eu so everyone's
a loser if they don't sort this out
quickly badisha bog off page two of the
times buy one get one free
well you bog off too uh okay so this is
about pounds of actual flesh versus
pound sterling you'll remember back in
2020 after his near fatal brush with
death uh uh having covered boris johnson
vowed uh that he would make sure that
there was a lot less post uh pre-9 pm
advertising of food that is high in salt
sugar and fat he was going to put curbs
on unhealthy food tackle the obesity
crisis tackle uh buy one get one free
offers two for one offers that actually
encourage people to buy more than they
need that's now on hold because under
pressure from all of his backbenchers
who are businessmen themselves and who
are also putting pressure on johnson to
get rid of unconservative ideas such as
the nanny state people telling people
that they're fat and they should eat
less and exercise more johnson is
dialing down holding back delaying by a
year all of these promises that he made
so don't expect any lessening of all of
these convenience food junk food adverts
promotions happening anytime soon
um page two of the telegraph matthew an
interesting one this um naznen zagari
radcliffe
being very candid with boris johnson
yeah i mean who wasn't impressed by
nazinee when she gave that press
conference a couple of months after
finally being released back to britain
from iran we should be absolutely clear
about this the people ultimately
responsible for her incarceration
sometimes solitary confinement
in iran was the iranian regime which in
my view is an evil regime but in 2017
notoriously boris johnson then foreign
secretary he said and it was wrong and
catastrophically wrong that nazine had
been teaching journalism over there that
was a terrible gaffe and nazanin
believes and iranian media i believe
have reported it to have been the reason
why she was kept in prison for longer
than she otherwise might have been so
she spoke truth to power when she met
the prime minister for the first time
after this ordeal yesterday in downing
street and said to him that she'd been
living in the shadow of his words for
four and a half years right badisha
let's let's skip a story shall we and go
to page 27 of the guardian because the
little trail i have here is brilliant at
the queen barbie doll has sold out you
got 30 seconds there you go
oh they made 20 000 of them you could
buy them for 95 quid from lovely john
lewis patriotic john lewis and then they
migrated onto ebay for double the amount
because capitalism but you can get these
lovely jubilee dolls there might be more
of them coming soon mattel or hinting if
you look at them not gonna lie she looks
pretty good she's gonna say she's living
there with a dash of kate blanchett yeah
it's a good look final story of the day
matt on you go uh a dog walks into pub
helen mirren with a dash of cate
blanchett i love that description
yes this is my favorite story i know
it's your favorite story is neil this is
the dog that went to the pub
this is in stockport in greater
manchester mark howarth was out i think
at a casino and he locked his front door
from the outside and of course he was
you're able to open it in this case from
the inside and that is exactly what
woody the rock violet managed to do he
opened the door from the inside strolled
down to the pub the local which is a a
whole mile away where apparently he's
given so many treats he absolutely loves
it turned up at the bar quite literally
and the barman then had to call mark to
tell him that he had his hand wonderful
opportunities for headlines of course
rovers return poorest a large one i just
love this story no no no the big
question is was he feeling rough the
next day uh matt padisha we will leave
it there thanks again always
entertaining
i will be back after this with more on
ukraine
[Music]